هنادي وجيهان قصه شغف ارتبطت بالرسم
فحاولتا بكل جهدا ان تصبح من المتميزات في
مجتمع ماربي محافظه اريد له ان يكون مغلقا
بدون فرشاه او معجون الالوان التي تستخدم
في هذا الرسم بل بالابره والخيطه تمكنتها
من صناعه لوحات فنيه غير تقليديه
اختلفنا من جهه اللون وبعد تفكير واتفاق
اتفاق اتمنى اللون الاسود والابيض لتعاكس
الالوان
رسمناها في تقريبا في تسع ساعات المقالح
عرضناها شفناها اقبال كبير من الجمهور
اعجب بها طلبوا منها الرسمات مختلفه من
مديريه حريب جنوبيه مارب حضر الكثير من
المبدعين في مجالات شتى وحضرت هنادي وجهان
بفن تشكيلي جديد ولان معرضه معرفه الثاني
للكتاب كان نافذه وابداعيه على العالم فقد
كان ايضا بوابتهما للشهره من خلال اللوحات
والرسومات التي لاقت رواجن كبيره حيث بدات
بشخصيه المعرض واديب اليمن الراحل عبد
العزيز المقالح
شاركه وحسينا احنا كمان فخر وكان في اقبال
كثير من الناس علينا والحمد
طبقنا اول تجربه شخصيه مشهوره والحمد لله
ضبطت معنا
وبعدين جربنا الثاني تجربه بعدين قلنا بقى
انا وهي محل الكتروني المتجر الالكتروني
يعني مفتوح وان شاء الله نحصل اقبال من
الاشخاص
ماربوا ارضوا الحضاره والتاريخ بموروثها
ومخزونها الانسانيه والاثري الشامل هي
المشروع القادمه لفتياتها المبدعات في
متجر الكتروني كان فكره وصار بعدها هذا
الاقبال جاهزا لطلب اللوحات الفنيه محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب